I don't need to express myself for going
to Twitter and tell people why I need oh
I should want to work here because I did
this I did that you're doing any answer
question no no you're the bug ding I
believe that I can be the best run guys
ever played again okay
leaving one hotel to head to the airport
because we're going to LA to interview
New York Giants running back state plum
Berkeley why are we going to LA to
interview a New York giant he's training
their sake one had an amazing rookie
season he was Rookie of the Year even
though he is one of the best running
backs in the league he doesn't said it I
have arrived let's interview sake lon
the crew is setting up are you reading
where you get these cheers oh yeah I
still see your goods are you ready
already what's the story behind your
name there's really no crazy message
behind it my full name is safe on my
suit Cuevas barkley say that again
slowly se Kwang soo Cuevas Barkley
Rasool he's one cent and Cuevas is a
name that my mom and my all kind of came
up with and they thought of a cute boy
name so when you two get in trouble
is your mama saying st. Claire oh so
Cuevas is she saying all them together
[Music]
were there any other names under
consideration besides say Kwan yeah to
pop you could have been to pop yeah to
partly to [ __ ] Machiavelli my dad's a
big 2/5 fan and I think the year before
Tupac died and he was trying to name me
to [ __ ] Machiavellian my mom was not
having that at all but how close were
weeds are having Tupac Bartley close
real close real close
it's my mom put her foot down how did
you know that Jada was the right name
for your one-year-old daughter we didn't
find out the generative bird which I
think was pretty cool so when she came
out we knew the name
set on Lamar it was gonna be a boy and
Jada was gonna be a girl
when she pushed out that baby baby said
Jada what scares you about fatherhood I
don't think it really anything scares me
your mistakes is now obviously in a
spotlight that reflects on your daughter
and your daughter's gonna know and you
know you and you also got to be man
enough to be honest about those mistakes
like my parents and my family was what
mistake that your parents made have you
learned the most from you know business
mistakes my father had a lawyer you know
drug history in the past dad my mom
helped him get through stuff like that
really helped me to become president
today what kind of person are you
great question type person I want to be
know what kind of person are you
oh right now right now I would say
hard-working a dad poking those five day
when you think you know more do you
realize that when you talk about
yourself you get so much more subdued
than when you talk about anything else
I didn't notice tough when you were at
the Pro Bowl ESPN asked you to make your
case for Rookie of the Year and I just
want to show you your answer okay
nothing taken away from from Baker he
had a tremendous year he different
browsers was unbelievable so definitely
must respect to him but I think you know
if you watch boom you watch my peers and
you see people that flavor gets to be a
coaches that play it gets me thinking
answer that question but and I can I
didn't really answer that question it
took you about 35 seconds to talk about
you I don't need to express myself worth
going to Twitter and going around ESPN
and tell people why I need all right
I said one cookie here because I did
this I did that no I don't I don't need
to do that and if I did that I wasn't
gonna help me win or lose anyway but
that's what everyone expects me to do
running back Jonathan Stewart said that
you can be the greatest running back and
of all time does Jonathan Stewart right
um you know got a lot of respect for
Jonathan Stewart you're doing answer
question no no you're you are the bug
ding okay how open iron is he right yes
I believe so I believe that I can be the
best one that's ever played a game that
good that hard I'm so proud of you you
won't say that you are the greatest at
anything except for Kinect for you claim
to be the goat yes I connect four
hundred oh no I can afford I mean I
haven't played in a minute but I am
obviously Michael Jordan took some elves
before in life so I get majority only
one person's up on me right now
no who's up on you I don't really want
to say never McCaffrey okay cocky you
know and I just made a wrong move and
got me I guess still bother me late
especially because it's Christian and
like I'll say that's my boy but you're
mine I'm back and I'm you competing at
each other so he's up me right now so
Christian if you see this any more event
will see today because you said you
wanted a big connect for we brought one
and we're going to play loser got
push-ups
Stuart don't know why just agree to that
I'll start first first position no hi
where's Rock Paper Scissors shoot
boom Rock Paper Scissors shoot
[Music]
no you don't rock paper scissors shoot
oh I knew what you were going through
okay your high school athletic director
Bob Hartman once described you as a kid
who's a pleaser he doesn't want to make
people angry
how much do you agree with that
assessment of yourself uh a lot anytime
someone is talking about you whether
it's your friends your family your
teammates that I'll use one word to
describe you nice are you too nice
sometimes sometimes I'm too nice yes but
I've been working on that because in its
industry you have to learn how to say no
and it's not just always about pleasing
other people um sometimes you gotta do
what's best for you why are you do you
put other people before maybe what you
want to do I feel like I'm a hard-ass or
anything I do
in what ways have you seen yourself try
to be more selfish you go from having
nothing and then 10 seconds having money
I guess you could say people come out
the Woodworks
you know everyone would be a part of you
keeping your circle tight and what about
taking care of them and I taking care
everybody else you could say that's when
I became a little more selfish
[Music]
it sounds good good switchover I like
that yeah but no if you doin here
you're dead me both way I know you what
do you think J - should I go here yeah
she says yes so if I lose its Christina
okay is it difficult for you to hear a
lot of the criticism that Eli Manning
gets as a quarterback yeah it bothers me
I'm gonna lie because it's it's not his
fault it's not the reason why we went 5
and 11 we lost 70 or seven or eight
games this year by seven points or less
as a team we'd love to put the blame on
one person but in a football it takes a
living man I'm fine with having only
1200 yards next year at their general
yard next year but what a 12-4 record
how crazy is it that there are people
out there who watched you play your
rookie year but still think the Giants
should have drafted a quarterback um
that's mind-boggling to me but tell me
why it's mind-boggling to you it's like
I think that what I was able to show not
only on the field but off the field that
they think they made a great decision
and what waves are um Baker Mayfield
similar work I think I would say if we
both able stay healthy and do we can do
that we might see each other - well one
day in what ways are you and Baker may
feel different um well they all say that
were different
[Music]
she's good
we're thinking of the second bank
different we think he's white I'm black
jacket I would say I was a difference
coming out of college uh he had to prove
something and I had to show what
everyone was saying was right and that
I'm even better whatever II was sitting
in I would say that was a difference
that we had to do in our Drive process
so he was trying to prove people wrong
mm-hmm you were trying to prove people
right yeah but also wrong cuz I'm better
know what they say no I'm not I am okay
look at this look at you do not with
them now that was good that's what you
need to be able to say that good enough
for that on there all right you and
Baker Mayfield recently went on a
vacation to Turks and Caicos who's more
fun on vacation I would say him
I love me I'll say he's probably more
fun cuz I had I come over like a ferret
do not mess with open water at all like
I don't mess with like sharks and fish
and stuff like that so wait when you're
looking about in the water about the job
what's going through your head just
saying please I'm gonna shave you down
they're like seeds do not look anything
like the Sharks does not only like the
scary thing in there I only mess with
dolphins like I'm nothing like I can't
be only one sitting out and then the guy
and shed bacon little D all in there and
I'm just sitting like hot and I'm not
doing that so I had to conquer my fear
and how they were doing without Stefan
said Baker there's definitely more fun
in the kitchen than me
but I'm getting better at it yeah what
do you think that's your biggest fear
though like open water um open water
my biggest fear I'm being high stakes
mm-hm
I don't miss it takes like takes like
the insect like the Internet right there
discussing like that's a very specific
thing to be scared of have you ever been
bitten by a tick yes I did I saw not
freaked out like I like straight butt
naked I like mom
my mama had like get it out yeah I still
flip my nosh so open water and ticks
make sure your opponents know it water
intakes that's happens I get to you I'm
just curious like this how you see like
you know what I mean like gaps or
anything it's not like chess but it's a
game that has it think steps ahead he's
had the one in like when you're playing
football you're playing a game you got
to think steps I have are you gonna sell
the defense tell you what side the
defender yeah obviously there's nowhere
near the level of what it actually is
but kind of similar to thank you so
whenever we have a guest we have them
answer a series of questions we want I
want you to take me to a certain time
place experience okay take me to your
leg workout hmm which one squats tell me
tell me the routine routine you know
quads Housley quads hamstrings how much
pride you taking your quads it was never
a thing at all like everyone said I had
big legs but like it was never like a
thing and people wouldn't like obsessed
with it I've got two NFL like now like
if I were a short shorts like I like an
airport in like a ladies were coming to
me but we'll do that nice ladies but
before that like oh you have nice legs I
was always tight legs taking me to your
go-to karaoke song it's Mario let me
love you how do you sing the Sun yeah
baby I just don't get it
I ain't gonna give you too much that's
one lies like I'm not singing my rap
career is gonna come or a little bit
later so like I say you you got to wait
I'd keep them tuned in a little bit I
kind of got you low key hang all that I
know I don't know like it doesn't matter
what I do you're gonna win yeah
just now you know well you know you know
uh Kirsten McCaffrey is still up so it's
cool
Kirsten Kaveri still the better connect
floor plan
that's crazy that's my move good for you
you're the better connect four player no
did you not agree to that I'll do one
five I don't even know if I can do one
damn I can't that too I can't dad three
four sink Juan what's good so it has
been like a couple weeks since I
interviewed you in LA and two days after
our interview Odell got traded it's sad
to see him go every time people come ask
me how you feel about death like
obviously that's my boy I'm upset like I
don't think anyone's gonna sit out and
say oh we're happy all those actually
but at the same thing it's a business
you know we gotta continue to work okay
so how do you see you know del since we
hung out it feels real like like it's a
thing like he walked in like with a
cleveland shirt because he was just done
working out and I was like Dan you'll be
in Cleveland shirt already you never
know one day hopefully we can compete in
a Super Bowl okay so an Adele is not on
the team anymore I mean what happens to
the dancing we're gonna try to get Eli
along with some dance moves suit
I know lastly I have to ask now Baker
and Odell are on a team together do you
feel a little left out no no you know I
do not feel left out at all
I'm happy for these guys all right we're
gonna wrap this video up with a selfie
we have rookie of the year right here
who was just fantastic in this interview
how to heal so much is amazing
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content